[Musique]
et on a travaillé beaucoup avec les
enfants malades les handicapés les
prisonniers les adolescents décrochage
l'idée c'est d'utiliser en fait ce
festival et la bande dessinée comme un
outil et c'est un outil redoutable pour
essayer de conquérir ou d'aller vers des
publics quant aux cas qui n'ont pas
accès à la culture
on va trouver l'équivalent de 25 auteurs
qui ont répondu présent dont qui seront
la démarche en démarchant donc qui qui
amène tout un toute une panoplie de bd
et de et de goodies et tout ce qui est
en lien avec la bd notre libraire
officielle qui sera là alors des
animations un caricaturiste des
expositions beaucoup d'auteurs ne
viendront pas notamment ceux qui
viennent de l'étranger parce que les
auteurs viennent du monde entier
donc on en a beaucoup qui ne vont pas
pouvoir venir non pas faute de pas
vouloir venir mais ils ne pourront pas à
cause de la fermeture des frontières et
donc en fait on revient presque
aux basiques c'est à dire que ça va être
un festival franco belge en 2009 si mes
souvenirs sont bons
le festival a été transféré au château
de buc qui est un site qui représente un
peu l'histoire de deux buts par rapport
à 14 et donc l'idée c'était de faire
venir les gens et de leur raconter aussi
l'histoire du lieu